midnight run uh is my favorite comedy of
all time
and joining me here on the rich eisen
show is the
chief tv critic and co-author of the
soprano sessions
uh from rolling stone who wrote a
terrific piece on the 30th anniversary
three years ago now uh of uh the
um the anna thirty year anniversary of
the release of midnight run calling at
the casablanca of buddy movies
alan seppenwall back here on the rich
eisen show how are you alan
i'm good rich i'm sad about grodden but
i'm i'm happy to be here to talk i
i wonder if it affected you as much as
it uh did me
i i just i don't i don't know just just
the fact that he was in a movie that it
means so much to me
and one of the lines that he said in the
film
um to robert de niro's character
uh jack walsh what they kept saying to
each other see you in the next life
now that he has passed away um i don't
know why that that that hit me it just
struck me
alan i was literally in the car with my
teenage daughter running errands
yesterday afternoon and we were quoting
from midnight run when someone texted me
and i asked her to check the phone and
she said dad charles grodin died
so that movie and his performance in
particular
are very important to me very important
to her very
to sort of the timing of it felt eerie
and it definitely
it threw me and it's it's a real bummer
because he's incredible in that movie
and then so many other things like this
talk show appearances you talked about
right
so what what about this film um
can you tell me about did because you
know it was 30 years uh 33 years ago now
and i remember
i seen it in the theater and i just
remember me being struck by it i was
such a deniro fan and just the way that
de niro and grodin
were perfect in the roles and with each
other
why do you think this movie worked the
way it did it's chemistry i mean
anybody movie requires dependent on
chemistry as much as a romance
or you know or an action movie or
anything else like you just need to
want to watch these two people bouncing
off of each other and so on
in one corner you've got intense angry
method actor
you know two-time oscar winner robert de
niro and the other you have this guy who
sort of had a
reputation both on screen and off has a
pain in the butt
you know he all sort of underplayed
everything uh was always getting the
feuds with people
uh and just sort of it was like watching
you know ali ropa dope george foreman
like
de niro keeps verbally swinging and
swinging
and groans just leaning back and taking
it knowing that he's gonna wear this guy
out
and he does repeatedly and it's just so
delightful
i've seen this movie more than i think
anything else ever made in cinema and it
never
fails to amuse me every time well i i
i'm wondering if you're
aware of of the making of it in any way
shape or form
was any of this um ad-libbed was this
all stuck to script
you're just the you know no no no i mean
one of the reasons uh
martin breast who directed the movie
really had to fight
to cast grodden the studio actually
wanted like
share to play the role they originally
wanted to be a romance and then when he
said no to that they wanted to hire
robin williams he said no
i've seen grodden screen test with de
niro he's perfect
and parts of what they did in the movie
is he there would be scenes
they're following the script and then
breast would say to to grodden
all right hey i just want you to riff
here and the most famous of those is the
theme
they're in the freight train they've
hitched a ride they're heading west
uh and he starts talking about like the
the chickens on the farm that they had
just been on and what breast had said to
grow right before the scene started was
look this is the crucial emotional
moment the conversation the two you're
gonna have together
we really need to get bob to open up do
whatever you possibly can
to make robert de niro laugh and he does
it and you see
de niro laughing the scene and it's
completely genuine because he was not
expecting
didn't you grodden to go off on this
roof about the chickens so that was
that was particularly ad-libbed right
there but anything else
the the thing with the litmus
configuration with the counter if it
builds
the idea was in the script but pretty
much all the dialogue is stuff
and came up with on the spot fantastic
and then what about the uh
how much is the coffee how much is the
tea 53 cents i'll have the tea and just
the way that he delivers those lines are
just
perfect they're spot on deadpan like
that that
just the timing of it is so perfect like
it's
that's a line that's not remotely funny
except for the way that he delivers the
right
pause he makes right before he says i'll
have tea
it's a killer yeah why do they call you
red for the
in the litmus configuration scene which
is what i i
i watched yesterday as well why did you
dye your hair
and then and then and then he goes
through the the insanity and then he
thanks him for his time
oh my god but you describing it as
making me laugh rich like that's how
great that performance was oh i i know
every line of this film you know
and and and yeah you know um and
tony darvo and hop along cassidy
you know being these two stooges that
dennis farina's
character in serrano puts on the trail
of the duke and ever and you know marvin
dorfler
played by john ashton who many fans of
obviously beverly's cop would know
um joey pants uh as moscow and the bail
bondsman
my god um just it's perfect and yet
if it you know with all due respect to
an oscar winner and share
what a what a save alan steppenwall
rolling stones alan sepulon
here we we had um kevin costner on the
show
uh a few times and one of the times he
was here he talked about how
um you know the original uh the the
studio
wanted robin williams again to maybe
play
costner right um in in
field of dreams and the director said
that you know uh ray concillo had to be
somebody who
you didn't believe was hearing voices
right
and yeah and he called that a mariano
like save
to to to keep costner in the role for it
what a save this was to because this
wouldn't have been one of the greatest
comedies of all time if it was a romance
i don't believe but turning it into a
bromance absolutely did in my mind
yeah i agree even robin williams he
would have been funny but i think he
he's too high energy as well so it's
sort of like you want opposites there
between him and de niro
and i don't know that you would have
quite gotten that and it's just
it's right up there on the screen it's
so palpable what they had together
no question about it um so uh as well i
know
you're you've got a couple other um
items
uh that you're constantly working on and
i i love all your work
you wrote a great article for rolling
stone about the 100 best sitcoms of all
time
um what what uh for those who may not
know what were your top five
on this one the top five
were um hold on no number one was the
simpsons
number two with cheers number three was
seinfeld
uh i'm sorry i'm just i think it's a
it's an incredibly long list
i'm sure i
i believe it lucy and the honeymooners
round out the top five
okay why why do you have the simpsons
number one
all-time first best sitcom it just it
did more
it did more for longer than anybody else
you know even
i hear people say well how can you put
the simpsons up top it hasn't been good
for 30 years and
hey i disagree with that but b even if
you accept that those 10 years
are so incredible and so wide ranging in
terms of the satire
and how many different subjects they
covered and how many like simpsons
quotes are applicable to any occasion
that's possible that i'm not i'm not
sure anything is ever going to be able
to quite beat it
and uh you put larry sanders at 10. i i
that that one is an unbreakable one that
might be my number one
sitcom um seinfeld is right up there
i'll be honest with you as well i'm an
old school guy the odd couple
for me the first couple of seasons
weren't
um you know the first season where there
was a laugh track not a live studio
audience but the odd couple with klugman
and randall were
that that is so formative for me that
sitcom
and you know shockingly you went into
sportscasting after growing up watching
the odd couple
well you should see my desk as well it's
uh it is uh
you know i was definitely not i
definitely uh gravitated more to oscar
than felix
on that front yeah no i i've i've yet to
meet a sports writer especially of a
certain age
who did not revere that show and i love
it and i think we put that somewhere
in the 50s it's fantastic what are you
watching now alan
what are you watching now oh what do you
see man the best thing i've seen so far
this year is a show on apple tv plus
called for all mankind
which is sort of an alternate history
where the russians beat us to the moon
landing
and as a result the space race never
ended and there have been two seasons so
far
and the second one is about the most fun
i've had watching anything on tv in
quite some time
okay what about something funny you got
was it ted lasso for you or i'm not to
give you
ted lasso was was really terrific i'm
very excited for that to come back uh
this summer that was that was something
that i think we all really needed during
the pandemic especially just
like a show about goodness you know
that's that
there's so many great shows and i've
written about them where the hero
is really not a hero at all and is is a
jerk and here you've got this guy whose
fundamental power is he's nice
before i let you go the new sopranos
documentary that you're in soprano
sessions a special theatrical triple
feature is playing nationwide
starting today did i read that it is is
it true
that the last time that um
that edie falco and
um and you know and james gandolfini
played
their roles in the sopranos was for a
video the knicks put together to try and
get lebron to come to new york is that a
true story
there's a true story jim was a big
knicks fan you know he he agreed to do
it he brought it
uh edie was friends with the filmmaker
so the two of them came together
to do it he had a beard on his face and
so they came up with some scenario where
tony and carmella were in witness
protection but still
inviting lebron over to to come and play
for the knicks and obviously it didn't
work
and it sounds like every copy of this
video has been destroyed is it really
and there's a part there's a part of me
that really wants to see it because i
imagine it was funny jim and eddie were
really funny in those roles
but there's a part of me that's like i i
want the show to have ended
with that scene in the ice cream parlor
and i never want to see tony soprano
as an adult again but you have so you
have not seen this
but you you can confirm that it did
exist that the knicks got them to
do it exist you know i don't think it
counts as incontinuity
especially you know if you're one of the
people who believes tony dies at the end
of the show
but like they made this several years
after the series ended but tony does die
at the end of the show right alan
uh rich we've had this argument before
maybe he dies and maybe he doesn't the
scene is about death
but not necessarily that tony's death oh
my gosh
then whose death is it you know of of of
parallel parking like is that
is it the death of parallel parking like
what i think it's about the idea that
anybody could die at any time it's not
really an
upbeat sort of note on which to end the
show but it's not like it was an upbeat
show to begin with
the death of the knicks trying to get
lebron so do we know if lebron ever saw
this video do we know if it was there so
they screened it for him in this
infamous
meeting that by all accounts was just a
complete disaster from beginning to end
come on
you know somebody should ask lebron now
that this has been talked about what he
thought of
the video so james dolan says press play
to somebody in the room
they they get rid of the powerpoint on
the screen and and
uh up pops gandolfini and eddie falco as
the sopranos and witness protection
saying that they're running the risk of
being found out but they still want
lebron to come to the knicks that
actually happened
in real life yes this is a real thing
that occurred a decade ago yes
wow we're all blown away right now alan
you should see our faces right here wow
um thank you for the time
i greatly appreciate it i literally
could talk about midnight run
for an entire three hours it really is
and i guess last question for you at
what point did you show it to your
teenage daughter how old was she before
you actually
i showed her a movie where he said maybe
maybe
she was 16 she might have been 15. it's
really mainly just about the profanity
not that like
i need to worry about her you know going
around repeating this stuff but i think
there's
there's an agreement with my spouse
about at what age
you know certain content gets exposed to
them yeah i know i mean
but but i guess every child does need to
know
that they are in control of their own
words because they're an adult
and if anybody ever says that to them
you can respond to the other person
saying here's two words for you
shut the f up like that that could
actually be
delivered like de niro to groden to know
why someone is unpopular with the
chicago police department
we could go on and on and on like lions
potatoes thank you so much
uh alex anytime richard let's do this
again thank you that's alan steppenwall
follow him on twitter i do you should as
well
he's also on instagram at seppenwall
s-e-p-i-n-w-a-l-l
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here